amid recent escalations and possible
russian war crimes in ukraine the eu is
trying to rid itself
of russian gas as quickly as possible
also considering that russia has
threatened to stop deliveries a timeline
however is unclear germany has activated
its energy emergency plan in order to be
prepared for a possible loss of russian
gas supplies if this were to happen
alternatives would have to quickly be
found now in 2021 russia supplied the eu
with 155 billion cubic meters of gas so
turning up the taps means
a big shortfall the united states has
committed to an additional 15 billion
cubic meters of gas this year supplies
could be delivered through europe
through various liquefied natural gas
terminals algeria has also agreed to
supply more gas if needed in increasing
its capacity by nearly three billion
cubic meters a year
other commitments are squishier the
international energy agency estimates
that countries like norway and other
baijan could increase their output to
the eu over the next year while other
suppliers like qatar canadia and
australia are already bound by long-term
supply contracts and cannot easily ramp
up production
all right for a closer look at this
let's bring in karen pittl she's the
director of the efo center for energy
climate and resources and she joins me
from munich welcome back to the program
karen um should the eu decide to boycott
rash russian gas deliveries it doesn't
look like the alternative sources can
fill the gap does it
no it doesn't i mean that's basically
unanimous from all of the sources that
you see trying to estimate how much is
possible that there is only a minor
increase possible with respect to
pipeline deliveries and a little bit
larger but also very uncertain increase
in the deliveries by lng
so of the 155
billion cubic meters that that we saw uh
last year how big a gap would remain if
europe were to tap all the sources
available
and basically estimates range from 10 to
15 billion cubic meters that could be
added through pipelines and
about 20 to 60 um via lng so there's a
high rate of uncertainty and we could
face something as low as like 30 billion
so that would make up about 20
uh that could be made up of the imports
um from russia up to something like 75
which would then amount to almost
45 50 percent but it's a high range of
uncertainty and
what we need to do is not only
get
gas from other sources but also reduce
uh demand and reduce usage of gas
um
germany is a
high heavily industrialized economy
obviously and the gap that you're
talking about um what would this gap
mean if we translated into loss of gdp
there's been a number of studies um done
on
exactly that questions and estimates
usually range in the short run between
minus three minus six percent of the
previous estimates of gdp development so
it's
a lot but it's not um unbearable now of
course there's a lot of discussion about
that because especially in the very
short run how fast can you actually use
substitutes how fast could you use for
imports for certain things how fast can
you do energy efficiency increasing uh
in increases so all of this is um rather
uncertain and the government is
basically frantically trying to hash out
what is possible and what is not
and uh all of this takes takes time of
course we know that for example the
terminals to receive liquefied natural
gas in germany are still under
construction that's certainly something
that cannot done
from today until tomorrow
karen tell us how long will it take for
germany and the eu to be completely
independent from russian gas should the
bloc decide uh wanting to do that
i mean that not only depends on on the
eu but also to a large extent on the
development of lng
shipping capacities from outside of
europe there is a small potential of
increasing gas production in europe that
has declined substantially over the last
decade basically
but the development of ports to ship
lng from is as important as the
development of the
ports to actually receive lng and of
course germany doesn't have own
terminals so far but there is a
construction going on of other terminals
in other eu countries and
in a network um like it is in the eu
there's of course also the possibility
for germany to get liquefied gas through
other ports
karen patel
director of the efo center for energy
climate and resources thank you for your
insights
you for having me
western countries want to become
independent of russian energy supplies
that's the idea but what are the
alternatives russian hard coal could be
replaced by coal from indonesia
while more demand for the country's
industry is certainly welcome
indonesia's government does have its own
concerns
at the beginning of the year the
indonesian government cracked down
imposing an export ban on coal but the
ban was only in force until the end of
january now coal ships are allowed to
head for international ports again as
long as domestic supplies are short a
quarter of the production must remain in
indonesia sold at prices set by the
government
exported coal on the other hand will
reap a bonanza for the coal companies
thanks to the sharp rise in prices on
the world market fueled by the russian
war of aggression in ukraine the price
of a ton of coal recently climbed to
over 400 us dollars
but coal rich indonesia is also focusing
on renewable energies for the long run
and wants to be carbon neutral by 2060.
indonesia
as a tropical country yeah we are
having a lot of sources of solar
and also beside that we have also wind
and then there also marine
energy source
we beside those
beside those technology we also expect
the development rapid development of the
energy storage system
at the moment however
climate-damaging coal is the country's
most important energy source for this
year the government expects production
to grow by eight percent
well for more on this let's cross over
to jakarta and journalist nadine
freischlar nadine how much is indonesia
profiting from coal buyers seeking
alternatives to russia
i mean indonesia has profited from
higher coal prices for a while now it
started i believe before the ukraine
crisis really took off
um and
i mean you would think definitely the
coal sector has has has had seen its
prices soar but as you mentioned earlier
there's also two forces that are
actually countering this effect which is
on one hand the indonesian government's
attempts to
force the coal producing companies to
reserve a certain amount of coal for the
domestic market and when you said
earlier 25
there's no talk of raising that to even
further to some 30 percent
so and then the other dimension in this
um that actually like increases pressure
on
the indonesian budget is that
as commodities prices rise the need for
subsidies also rises because it's been
important to the indonesian state to
keep certain prices for fuel
for for gas consumer friendly and very
low and that means we'll need to
continue subsidizing
uh which which increases the pressure on
the state budget now not long ago
this year
actually indonesia's leadership issued a
temporary export ban on coal is there
concern that the government could do
that again anytime soon
there's no more talk of an export
outright ban
there is talk of increasing the domestic
market obligation a little bit further
so i think the the balance of those two
uh i mean the balance of the domestic
market obligation is where it's going to
be at i haven't heard anything about
a new ban
indonesia is the world's biggest
exporter of thermal coal but it is
reliant on oil and gas imports could it
benefit uh from a possible western
boycott of russian oil
i mean that's the thing unlike uh some
western countries indonesia hasn't said
that it won't you know take advantage of
cheaper prices on the market and i think
pertamina the state
oil company is is making plans to
purchase russian oil at lower costs
again because
you know higher prices in indonesia mean
that the government has to pay a lot for
subsidies and so it's purely an economic
decision to look for cheaper prices on
the market
now despite its heavy entanglement in
the commodities business indonesia also
wants to become carbon neutral by 2060
as we heard in the report uh possibly
sooner than 2060. how far along is the
country on this path
i would say
it's still it's still a long road indeed
um what we have heard
the ministry say is that
a new bill for new and renewable
energies is supposed to be passed by the
third quarter of this year which will
finally give a little bit more concrete
plans for how the energy transition is
going to be achieved
what has happened already is that
one or two of more utility scale solar
systems have come
um have have begun building i don't
think any of them have actually come
online yet
so it's really still very in the early
days and in my views
um
certain decisions for example to
actually um delay the rollout of the
carbon tax again which was supposed to
take effect this month but they have
said let's postpone it again for another
quarter three months or so those are all
signals that it is still very difficult
to
implement policies that could hurt the
traditional sectors journalist nadine
freischlad reporting from jakarta thank
you
you